[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu sempre falo que eu não dei à luz pra
maria
na verdade foi a maria que deu à luz pra
mim quando assim eu nasci cheia de luz
acreditando nas pessoas acreditando no
mundo acreditando em todos os passos que
é dar tudo ia dar certo que tinha muita
segurança onde eu estava e aí com o
tempo escola trabalham família amigos e
fui colocando um monte de máscaras e eu
fui virando uma outra pessoa
então eu tinha que me formar eu tinha
que fazer faculdade é o que fazer pós a
de conseguir estágio ainda e aí eu fui
pra ninguém eu fui acreditando nesse
sistema
eu fui realmente achando que esse era o
caminho até que eu engravidei um susto
e aí essa pessoa que trabalhava muito
muito muito muito estudado e fazia mil
coisas parou eu falei 'o a rua e agora e
aí
primeiro veio uma lista sobre todas as
coisas que eu tinha que comprar pra
minha filha para ir para a maternidade
era uma lista de lado e vocês devem ter
acesso a isso não é uma lista de 200
coisas que o chá de bebê né
aí olhei aquele falei gente é desse
tamanho
o meu irmão até brincou falou como é que
os índios fazem
e aí eu falei não faz muito sentido
só que estava sozinha mãe tava morando
em portugal e eu fui a única das minhas
amigas que engravidou então eu não tinha
muito rede de apoio não sabe onde
procurar muita informação eu nunca
imaginei semana e não foi uma busca foi
uma surpresa e aí eu falei bom então vou
sentar com a voz da maria e com a
madrinha da maria e aí eu vou perguntar
e foi assim que eu fiz sentei com a
lista de 200 itens e arriscou e se
relacionarão 50 coisas dessas 50 coisas
a maioria deve ser usado umas 30 e eu
comecei entrar
em vários questionamentos sobre o
consumo ea infância quando a gente vira
mãe quando a gente entra no mercado
muito maluco de coisas que eles fazem a
gente acreditar que são muito
importantes
e aí você começa então a então é muito
importante eu tenho que fazer quantos
pré-natais quantos exames o que eu tenho
que fazer
você começa a ter uma lista de coisas
pra fazer e você começa a se esticar e
você não pára muito pra pensar você só
tem que fazer aquilo
toda vez que eu ia no médico mas que
nunca perguntou como é que eu tô me
sentindo tão o time sozinho
olha tem uma rede de apoio aqui super
bacana pra você não era quando está
pesando não pode engordar mais de 12
quilos é esta a pressão está ok
e aí eu falei ah então é assim
aí a maria nasceu quando a maria nasceu
começaram todos os meus questionamentos
será que eu preciso mesmo de um trocador
um pote procurou net um pote com algodão
mas não sei o quê
aí eu comecei a perceber que não gostava
de nada daquilo sabem que aquilo era só
um monte de coisa que não fazia o menor
sentido para a gente assim
e aí a gente foi então questionando ea
criança ela tem muito isso é de
perguntar os porquês a criança ela tem
esse pessoal coisa do mas porque
responde porque sine
ela fala porque assim não fica assim uma
resposta ela quer entender o porquê é de
verdade e eu acho que os porquês da
maria foram iluminando os meus próprios
porque sá e aí aquela criança que eu fui
quando eu era ali pequenininha ela foi
crescendo junto com a maria ea gente foi
questionando todo o sistema sim
absolutamente tudo do dia das mães até o
natal
absolutamente tudo o que é o dia das
mães é preencher no shopping foi pegar
uma super fila comprar um monte de coisa
é isso mesmo será será que pode ser
diferente é que a gente pode contar uma
nova história então foram esses
questionamentos que a gente foi entrando
quando a maria nasceu eu coloquei ela
pra mamar e eu tinha visto das
propagandas que vocês já viram que
aquela maravilha vamos lamentar esta
criança
só que comigo e talvez com muitas de
vocês não foi assim
não foi esse lugar natural e tinha muita
dor e muita muita muita dor e eu falei o
problema sou eu tenho problema eu não se
amamentar uma criança eu tenho culpa eu
sou uma mãe horrorosa todas as mães
colocam a criança no peito e mama porque
você não mama e aí eu comecei a falar
até passar um enfermeiro falava olha não
consiga aumentar minha filha ela falava
público do seu peito
agora num ela está invertida não vai não
vai dar certo isso aí eu falei mas eu
quero é meu sonho eu quero amamentar
minha filha eu quero muito não vai pegar
pela própria pessoa e aí começar novas
mas tem uma fórmula para ela tomar que é
incrível é igual ao leite materno
consumo e aí eu falei gente mas não tem
como ser igual ao leite materno não faz
sentido sem igual o leite materno e aí
então sozinha
falei eu vou até o fim eu colocava uma
toalha na boca por dia com bastante
força pegava na outra mão e apertava e
dava o leite do peito com pedro
sangrando
foi assim durante três meses e depois
foi uma maravilha e foi tudo como
acontece nas propagandas com que vocês
assistem
só que demoraram três meses eo quanto de
publicidade que eu consumi am foi
fazendo eu acreditar que a maternidade
era uma coisa que não era e os livros
que eu lia sobre cuidar de filho e todas
as informações e tem muita informação
esse é o problema é tanta informação que
você não sabe o que fazer e aí foi a
hora que eu virei e falei bom agora
chega eu preciso olhar pra dentro e ver
o que realmente me importa o que
realmente importa
e aí foi crescendo essa mãe com essa
criança ea gente foi se questionando e
foi andando pelo mundo e fui colocando
na escola e quando falava vou colocar
maria na escola e as pessoas falavam
olha você esse tipo de mãe que você é
que eu sou um tipo de máquina este tipo
de mãe que você é uma mãe mas assim
construtivista coloca numa escola em que
tenha mais a ver com você né
só que aí você começa a perceber que a
escutam
quem está ali como um produto né então
você vai colocar o filho na casinha aí
você vai trabalhar na outra casinha e
ninguém se fala do trabalho não falar
com a sua maternidade que não fala com a
cozinha da escola que não fala com
ninguém
um monte de muros né nem da sua casa tem
da escola seu filho é você coloca joga
um coloca no outro mas só arrumando os
bonecos assim eu falei cara não vou
falar numa escola onde eu perceba a
abertura para diálogo
coloquei na primeira festa da escola da
minha filha de uma festa junina tinha
prenda e aí na prenda era brinquedos de
meninos e meninas né
aí a maria virou e falou assim quero
esse cara de menino
aí a professora falou assim olha não dar
esse é de menino eu falei ela quer é
esse
a iata não tá bom tá bom tá bom ela
pegou um brinquedo e deu pra minha filha
e aí eu voltei pra casa e falei porque
isso incomodou tanto que até então não
tinha parado para pensar sobre gênero um
gênero como assim
e aí eu comecei então estudar eu preciso
entender esse negócio de genética na
escola da minha filha mônica de
informação e fazer uma transformação
porque não adianta a gente ficar no
nosso mundinho de gente que pensa igual
a gente tá na hora de encher para um
outro lugar de começar a transformar em
torno da gente e aí eu falei falei com a
escola dela foi lá
a aluna aplicada explica sobre gênero ea
diretora falou faz todo sentido
vamos mudar isso vamos mudar e aí a
gente mudou
e assim foi com absolutamente tudo teria
uma coisa que eu não consegui mudar na
escola dela por ele teve algumas coisas
tão mais uma das coisas foi uma na lista
de material estavam três estojos para
uma criança pequena pequena num estúdio
da caneta grossa na outra caneta fina na
outra lápis caneta e borracha super
importante afinal ela tem 56 anos
então se é fundamental três torres aos
seis anos de idade
e aí eu falei aí tinha que também
etiquetá um por um para saber que aquela
caneta élan e aí eu falei pra minha
filha eu falei filha não faz sentido ela
falou mãe para de brigar eu preciso ser
igual às crianças
tipo não não te quer tam e tinha uma dor
ali tipo eu quero pertencer todos nós
queremos pertencer e aí eu virei e falei
o álbum é detectar e passei uma noite
inteira etiquetando caneta por caneta
sim fui à escola deve falar n
não concordo com isso tem outra maneira
de a gente fazer
ela falou mais caron para aprender um
monte de coisa com isso ela vai aprender
a cuidar das coisas dela
aí eu falei assim olha eu tenho uma
idéia é sair com cada mãe com uma caneta
um jogo do planeta
aí colocam jogo de caneta e todo mundo
espera que todo mundo espera as canetas
é todo mundo pega sua pede licença pra
mim aprendi várias coisas nacionais para
eles em si tal aí ela falou mais mas ela
aprender a cuidar do que a dela eu fui
lá pra aprender a cuidar o que é de todo
o mundo
está na hora da gente começar a aprender
a cuidar o que é de todo o mundo assim
como essas crianças dessas mulheres
grávidas assim como os homens assim como
todos nós
a gente está muito nesse lugar do
buraquinho da gente do indivíduo e é
isso
só que todos nós somos um só é verdade
se tem uma mãe sofrendo é parte de você
também
então o quanto a gente tem que começar a
olhar para o todo o quanto essa empresa
tem que começar a olhar para essa mulher
que está grávida
essa mulher que tem um filho pequeno pra
esse pai também que muitas vezes sofre
porque queria ficar mais tempo dentro de
casa então assim nasceu um dia das
crianças da minha filha e começaram a
perguntar o que é que eu daria pra minha
filha de presente de dia das crianças
aí eu fui pra paulista eu sabia que uma
feira de trocas lá ea empolgada dar só
levei minha filha minha filha de um
barco enorme gigante maravilhoso que o
artista tinha feito a gente paga uma
fortuna porque a gente gosta de comprar
direto do pequeno produtor então
chegamos nessa feira e aí foi incrível
para mim porque a paulista aquela
movimentação maluca tinha um grupo de
pessoas parado conversando pais mães
crianças brincando
eu falei cara para viver esse lugar aqui
ó tipo é isso as crianças elas negociava
os brinquedos de uma maneira muito
interessante que era eu tenho essa
boneca gigante aqui e quero ficar com
você mas a sua boneca é pequena não mas
a ela pegava três bonecas botava uma em
cima da outra
três bonecas e agora trocam então o
valor era outro ali e os pais estavam
carros não queria ficar na loja é que a
gente fica tenso né é caro e se não não
os pais estavam relaxados estavam
dividindo e estavam falando é difícil né
isso aqui né
é difícil e ainda falei nossa ninguém
está postando foto do bebê feliz eles
estão falando das dificuldades deles
eles estão se abrindo as pessoas vão
conversando estão ajudando a criança que
está correndo e quase se machucou o pai
que nem era dela não é o painel foi lhe
ajudou salvou a criança eu falei nossa
isso é muito legal isso fala de
colaboração isso fala de compartilhar
isso fala em sustentabilidade fala de
amor fala de tantas todos os valores que
eu fiquei completamente despropositada
assim eu falei isso e aí eu voltei pra
casa com todas essas coisas lá a minha
filha trocou o barco por um espelho
desse tamanho era desse tamanho mesmo e
ela andava na paulista
olhava o espelho fazer
foi ela o barco é o menor atenção mas o
espelho era o espelho sabe assim ela
ficou muito feliz com o espelho e se
pela inclusão até hoje
e aí eu voltei pra casa e falei vou
montar alguma coisa que falha para as
pessoas sobre tudo isso e aí é manter o
quintal de trocas que a empresa que o
trabalho hoje e que eu amo fazer que tem
todos esses esses mortes esse lugar de
onde eu acredito que a gente sair desse
lugar do um individual do sozinho e vai
pessoa teia de comunidade de amor do que
realmente me faz sentido dentro de mim
eu tenho uma um sonho assim um sonho que
gostaria muito que as crianças pudessem
sair na rua brincar
olha o carro olha não sei o que é assim
quando a minha filha na rua e eu
gostaria que fosse mais livre sabe que é
tanto a minha criança eu a minha própria
criança pudesse brincar mais com uma
criança da minha filha também pudesse se
divertir mais
o mundo onde fizesse mais sentido de
verdade onde a gente pudesse fazer a
cidade pensando na criança
e aí nessa cidade todos nós teremos
muito bem vindos e eu queria que a gente
pensasse sobre o que realmente importa
obrigada
[Aplausos]